in this country its Hollywood but in
India its Bollywood both are enormous
centers of film production still it's
quite rare to find one performer who hit
it big in both places that is the story
of actor Irfan Khan who passed away this
week mt st op reports earth on Khan
burst onto the global stage with the
mega hit Slumdog Millionaire where his
performance as a suspicious and vicious
police inspector thrilled audiences
reasons to make most mistakes in life it
looks like he'll mix up a boot and
Hollywood where he'd star along the
likes of Tom Hanks not my best work
dinosaurs in Jurassic world think it uh
scary the kids kid and that's who we're
diggin in angley's special effects opus
like four pies but it's cons quieter
roles like in the art house masterpiece
the lunchbox he'll be most remembered
for but sometime you let me into dreams
and I want to thank you for that
born in 1967 to a middle-class Muslim
family in western India
Irvin Khan made his film debut in the
oscar-nominated classic Salaam Bombay a
performance that propelled him into
careers spanning three decades and over
70 films including the namesake a vivid
snapshot of the first generation Indian
American experience Khan died of cancer
on Wednesday in Mumbai I suppose in the
end the whole of life becomes an act of
letting go but it always hurts the most
is not taking a moment to say goodbye
recipients this morning Saturday in
pious tired London and Khan is not the
only lost Bollywood is feeling another
huge star Rishi Kapoor died this week as
well just a day within each other he was
one of Bollywood's most popular actors
over the last 50 years Dana